stormy weather in the midwest has
finally quieted down this morning after
another round of deadly tornadoes a
twister touched down in Louisville last
night causing significant damage and
possibly one death this follows a
massive tornado that is blamed for at
least five deaths in Southeastern
Missouri Adriana Diaz is on the scene in
the town of Glen Allen that's about 100
miles south of St Louis Adriana good
morning
good morning this is the biggest church
in this community and we learned last
night that two people who were living in
a trailer home when they heard those
tornado warnings going off they ran here
for shelter and they survived an ef2
tornado hit this town in what's been an
unusually active and early tornado
season
I heard the reward coming through
around 3 30 Wednesday morning a massive
tornado packing winds as high as 130
miles per hour carved straight through
Glen Allen in rural Southeastern
Missouri
it was breathtaking I don't even know
it's just the mess that there is the
trees that are down at least five people
were killed you hear a bunch of wind
just like a train coming Keith and
Shannon Lincoln were home when the
Twister hit I had a carport back there
it's gone and then our detached garage
which it took I think it took the most
damage they rode out the storm in their
bathroom where they prayed they'd be
spared I could say we were blessed we
got very lucky lucky they survived when
others did it we lost some good
neighbors down the road and the whole
family
this deadly storm came just a few days
after dozens of Twisters upended
communities from Iowa to Delaware
killing at least 33 people Louisville
Kentucky is the latest scene of
Devastation yesterday an ef1 tornado
tore through ripping the roof off this
apartment complex
it's just one of dozens of Twisters that
have struck the South and Midwest over
the last two weeks leaving debris and
Devastation in their wake there she is
over the past two weeks more than 60
people have died in tornadoes in the U.S
nearly three times as many as all of
last year I've seen some pretty bad
storms but no nothing like this
residents here in Glen Allen told us
they're used to tornado warnings in this
part of the country but this town is
usually spared this time they took a
direct hit the governor says the cleanup
could take months which is obvious and
he spoke to the president who offered
his support and Aid Vlad
absolutely heartbreaking for those who
lost their lives Adriana and prayers for
those who survived thank you very much